okay so we got the puppet master and the
funny thing is I was talking to rob I
think it was like the end of season 1 or
something like I think we're talking
about the moon thing with the moon being
blocked and would that really stop all
the water bending if waterbending was
real alle and and I said well that
doesn't explain the biggest hole in the
whole thing which is that if they can
really water Bend they should be able to
move anyone because majority of her
bodies are made of water and browser
went um wait for it and he just gave a
little wink a like just wait for it and
obviously this is the episode he was
talking about so I I'm not used to this
I'm not used to something not making
sense or not adding up and it will be
explained I think this comes from
reviewing movies so that when something
is over it's over so this this idea that
stuff will be explained I I'm curious if
this came from people writing notes or
saying hey what about this or if this
actually was planned from the very
beginning of Brighton most of it
probably was playing from the very
beginning some of it you know they got
notes out like the foaming mouth guy
it's like bring him back so um but uh
okay so you got this episode this is an
episode where they come across this
waterbender in the fire Kingdom and
she's been manipulating people when it's
full moon and she becomes her most
powerful and she can blood Bend which is
gone and well what a great name for it
and it's sort of like this taboo I guess
you're not supposed to do it because
it's just too powerful that maybe they
don't quite I don't say they don't go
into why specifically because you see
this woman go crazy but I do sort of say
well okay if one crazy person I mean I
get it I mean the message came through
but it's also served like you know we
are at war and I I don't know you you
say okay you side with her even though
she's nuts a little too much to totally
say well yes not bad I error that's
that's a bad idea
where
the other side doesn't make as strong an
argument they just sort of say it's
wrong and that's it and I it gets his
point across well enough but it could've
done to touch stronger at just making
her nuts and a psychotic I don't think
it's enough I mean usually that stuff is
it's a well look at what did to this
crazy person but the this is a little
bit more there's a little bit more
wiggle room here I think they Cove
address but regardless so this woman is
uh taking people and keeping them like
imprisoned and barely feeding on my
thing I pretty much treating them the
way she was treated when she was a
prisoner of the fire nation which was
also very effective flashback I love the
I love the part where shows all the
waterbenders disappearing and she's
still fighting uh slowly she just stops
and you circle around and see she's
totally surrounded by the the soldiers I
thought was a pretty effective shot and
it's very obvious this is a good episode
it's a very dark episode and it's the
closest one all of this is obviously for
anime style but this is the closest one
I was watching and I had to remind
myself I wasn't watching an anime
episode particularly when it cut to a
flashback of the first season I realized
somewhere there there must have been
switch or they did something different
with the animation because like the
first episode that they cut to the
colors were so bright and so vibrant and
they so stood out against the
backgrounds which is in that's more
American anime they serve blend in a
little bit more with the backgrounds
like the the line work and the color
work it's it's sort of like hero you can
tell this is background but I'm not I
don't stand out that much in front of it
you can time in my environment and anime
very much usually likes to do they
usually likes to make it look like
they're very much in their environment
as opposed to stand out from their
environment to make them more visually
appealing so it's yeah give or take
different styles but this one they
really really mixed it in and probably
because of the the darks and the shadows
and the grays and stuff like that it's
very
effective and is a very dark episode and
you know of course there's lob Dark
Elves this is definitely a very I mean
the angles they get and serve the
psychotic lady and the likes a lot of
it's at night during like the full moon
and stuff and even starts off with a
ghost story and the funny thing is I'm
watching it and I'm saying to myself
they obviously wanted to go dark this is
one of the few instances where maybe
because it's a show for children as well
as adults they couldn't go as dark as
they wanted to I mean just say that
blood bending think about what you could
do with this and think about the ending
as well Katara finally has to do a
little bit in order to save her friends
who is she's gonna force to kill
themselves as she saves them by stopping
the lady pretty much and the lady's like
haha my job is done you have officially
become a blood vendor moo-ha-ha guitars
cries and this is really that bad what
happened I mean she stopped someone from
she controlled someone's body to stop
her from killing two other people is now
is she blew her up she just cuz
honestly what I your blood pending
that's the first thing I felt like oh so
you can just make a person at explode if
you wanted us to get but it's it's
avatar you can't do that but if you're
gonna go this dark that's sort of the
only way around it I can see and and
granted they try their hardest to make
the blood bending like disturbing like
the actual and unnatural the way they
actually do the movements and they even
add sound effects almost like you can
hear the blood flowing through the
bodies and the cranking the kick I mean
it looks like something like out of the
Exorcist or the ring or something em you
wanna seem like crawling backwards or
something and a sped up so it it looks
very unnatural which is good and creepy
but if they really want to get the
message they wanted to get out in this
at the M which is Katara has this
ability in her and there's some point
where she'll have to be forced to do it
as well and there is no extreme this is
never right at some point you know
there's going to be an exception to the
rule and it really eats her up inside
she had to do something worse than this
this isn't even bad what she did at the
end um so I got it I mean the point got
across it's still good episode and it's
so effective it's effectively creepy
it's a it shows good arguments to both
sides of the argument of the debate but
I still even though she's insane I still
kind of side a little bit more with the
philosophy of the crazy lady and that I
don't think that's the point wants to
get across um well if anything you
probably wants to get across that as
much as we don't want to deal with
certain elements as much as we want to
say it's never right to do this it's
never right to do that there will never
be a time to do it there will never be a
time do that chances are again that
there are most likely going to be
exceptions to the rule and and that's a
tough thing to deal with um I I just
somewhere in there there's like this
really friggin brilliant oh my god can't
sleep at night story hear it but it
couldn't quite be brought out I think
because it is Nickelodeon it is a
cartoon for children as well as adults
and I mean okay I'm kind of amazed they
could again I'm amazing and go away with
what they have so far and they could do
it as professionally as they have but
this is one of those elements where okay
you want to dabble with this and it's
effective but it could have been more
effective maybe a little bit more
suggesting what she did to other people
or even the rats or something like that
um maybe at some point she did kill with
them I mean the idea of keeping them
alive and just starving them
okay just starving em I mean okay that's
a nasty thing to do but and it does tie
in to doing like what they did to her in
the prison so it makes sense just to
keep them alive just barely alive uh but
if you really want to go into like the
real evils of this you kind of got to go
all the way but I understand I
understand you can't and you couldn't um
that does raise the question whether or
not this should have been done then in
this manner I think it's okay to serve
okay like hey this is a taboo thing but
they don't go quite enough into it it's
more hinted at why it shouldn't be done
and why it is too much power
um so I don't know it's a good episode I
mean there's it's by no means bad it is
it is good and it's effective and gets
the point across
just enough yeah but again I it's it's a
tough position to be in it's if you
can't do this idea all the way do you do
it at all and that's it that's a
difficult compromise especially in a
family show especially on a show like
this which is I mean in my opinion just
push the envelope on what family shows
can do and get away with so yeah it's
still good I mean I'm glad I watched it
I mean I don't think it's my Emmys
filler I think it's important to address
this because I was are questioning that
like oh well why couldn't they do this
why couldn't they do that but something
very important I was gonna bring this up
in the last one is that you got and
again this is sort of what family films
can get a family from family shows can
get away with uh but just something
really good should be able to get away
with either I think sir often was our
Arthur Conan Doyle gabbro Sherlock
Holmes he had sort of an interesting
quote about this - I think it's him
don't don't quote me on that quote but
he was talking about how the details
never quite fast
and his thing was the major story and
the characters and the core focus and so
on
and by the time this comes out I
probably won't release in the stash
Creek out already
it's about nitpicking when it's right
and what it's wrong and I think it's the
same thing here where if you're focusing
that much on this the shows probably not
doing its job right or you probably
focus on this too much if you do it for
everything and you can enjoy it um but
yeah with avatar I mean I don't know
there's probably a couple dozen other
instances where I'm like where I
comprise it well why didn't they use the
waterbending here why couldn't the
earthbending do this well wait if if
earthbending can move mountains and
canyons how could the Fire Nation you
know this should be over in a minutes
like a lot of stuff I'm saying wait a
minute
I'm it's not a problem because the
emotion is there and the stories are
there and that is what the focus is
supposed to be so I like the fact that
they are addressing these details they
are addressing these issues that hey you
know I'm probably fair amount people
would bring up um but again seeing how
it's a family show also meant for
children children wouldn't bring it up
as much and I like that when they bring
up these elements like why not blood
bending or is this possible it's not as
much heywhere explain this because
you're going to call and say hey why not
this there explain it because it's
introducing a new idea that you may not
have thought of or a younger audiences
may not have thought of and I really
enjoy that I like when it sort of says
hey we're gonna throw us in there but
not because you're a nitpicking dweeb or
something we're throwing it in because
it's an interesting idea and we want to
explore it a little bit so that's the
sign of an interesting show when you're
not paying it or interesting movie or
anything when you're not paying
attention to the details you're not
being distracted by stuff that you're
not being distracted by stuff that
couldn't happen but instead you're
paying more attention to what can happen
and they can even surprise you with
stuff you didn't even think could happen
and that's what's great fun about this
show and they constantly do over a No
over and over so yeah sorry that turned
a little long-winded there I know me but
yeah so there it is it's it's a good
episode I'm glad I saw great angles
great shadows and grays and a nice
pallet of dark colors in this one and
you know interesting definitely
interesting ideas going on here and
taboo ideas and explains why this isn't
why this war can't be done in two
seconds with the water nation so that
just maybe could have been no if only
wasn't quite a family show I I guess I
would been interest to see what they
could get away with or what their
original idea was if this was not a
family show so it's still good still
strong stuff uh yeah that's it for this
one and I'll see you in the next one